hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Cup heads so I think
we might actually be pretty close to
done with this island I don't actually
know where there would be anyone else
unless they're up over this yonder way
but it looks like that's a nope I think
I got everybody here so let me through I
gotta get to the next inkwell aisle
three hello hi hello how you doing looks
like I might have underestimated your
Cup face you gave it to them Dennis but
good go on over to the next Island lots
of fun times waiting for you there
alright thank you can't wait to kill you
okay see ya boy you you this this
brilliants the picture of our casinos
destroy lives
the little mugs have some fat in them I
say that much they're making mincemeat
out of them debtors you see I knew there
was something special about those
fellows well don't be too sure just yet
boss I think there's something fishy
about those two don't blow your wig dice
if there's two little things try
anything yeah I'll be waiting okay all
right well that's ominous of you but
I've got some tricks up my sleeve of my
own so I'll have you know that you're
stupid and I'm gonna punch you in your
face and dick in that order okay honey
come Harold alright what have you got
for me I just love the way you just roll
right in the ball okay if it's gonna
this is gonna suck I can already tell
this is this go oh boy
hey oh god everything is hard to see
here alright alright alright man is this
is a depressing work environment I could
have slapped with that but I was too
busy worried about my survival yeah I
had too high for this level oh oh no you
got a bruised shoulder I'm not sad at
all about that okay huh what are you
doing what's that all about
don't be like that what are you done oh
whoa oh are those slappable yeah yeah
I'm gonna try here we go no no no oh god
I was totally fine and then I
oh that that's weird okay you know what
I don't like that at all
whoa okay that's no good you know I
gotta admit Queen B your your ear powers
are a little bizarre and odd and
peculiar but whatever you say hey guys
it's good no no no that looks pink and
slappable bears track I'm not gonna try
I love it
I can't slap him can't slap him they
look slappable but you know no no no no
that's not slappable that is non sir I
am NOT your dinner okay I'm not I swear
boy boy boy boy what's going on here ah
I don't know you know what that was I
can't do let that stand
now go I guess whatever you say buddy
boo Jim where you going nope I could
have slap at that but better the plants
safe I suppose oh hey well that's that's
a might bit close gray no I wasn't
watching where my footing was got him
kill these poor worker bees this is so
sad they just come in here with their
menial jobs in their lifetime of
servitude and I just gotta be a dick and
shoot him man I am an a-hole that much
was evident I guess wait what is oh no
oh what the hell why I don't get the
right platforms huh go take the
platforms away from me snacks in my
skill that's undermining me you your
platform [ __ ] come on what do you
get that's gonna be the weird spheres
and I like dates fairs especially don't
like the fact that they're pink and
looks laughable they are slappable but I
can't run into it when I slap him
alright one more time one more time one
more time this is gonna be the one
there's gonna be the one this is gonna
be the one this is gonna be the one
there's gonna be the one boy no I jumped
into it
god damn it god damn it god damn it guys
still got this also why is there why is
our whole hive full of boiling honey
that seems less Eames bizarre and
unnecessary you know like a lot of
things in this world seem pretty bizarre
and unnecessary so I guess I shouldn't
complain about Oh God well that's me now
I'm gonna die this round on yes
I am yes I am I just want to see the
third phase though all I really want
will hello snap nope ha ha ha hey yah
are you gonna do the triangles I don't
like the triangles oh I hate the
triangles actually I have to be
perfectly honest about something in this
place that I actually hate it might be
the triangles well that's that's
different nope take my milk I think I
think that's what you're taking ah
that's not good
oh don't like that I don't know what's
above nope don't like that nope do not
like that
where's why I don't like that at all No
oh this is the opposite of good I mean
they're not too hard to dodge whoa whoa
oh yeah look at me look how good I am
everybody's looking at how good I am Bob
so good okay yeah I didn't parry a
goddamn thing but hell yeah I don't even
know what skill levels all about but
hell yeah oh hell yeah get rekt be bad
as an office building wasn't okay I
don't believe that for a second well
rumor honey bottoms
okay all right poor rumor rumor is
extremely dead now
ello pirate aren't you cute you're Funko
are you're gonna need some tips if you
want to kill all these deadbeats start
by mixing up your weaponry can't expect
all your arms to work for this same on
every full mix and match landlubbers
that's what I say
alright well if you say so I'm gonna go
change up to charge precision is key I
think that might be fun or aggravated
one of the two I always get the two
mixed up all right how about you
landlubbers shooting in Luton all right
I'm down let me shoot and let me loot
all right I don't know how this one
works
poink woo I like it oh that was dodge
ball
Lebowski I hope that hey I don't even
know if it here yeah oh it's not I
didn't hit you at all I'm sorry I didn't
even come close to hitting you that's
not good oh whoa whoa what the hell whoa
whoa whoa Dogfish that ain't that ain't
right okay how about this again okay
down here yeah that come from oh I see
it Oh No ah [ __ ] [ __ ] shitty tits and
it's pretty good for my first try not
bad okay
well easy enough let me try the other
one Oh see yeah this is gonna be that's
gonna be a problem because I can't just
like always focus in on that there we go
that's how you do this guy seems pretty
easy I'm not gonna lie I mean I'm not
gonna jinx it or anything but whoa whoa
okay never mind not easy not easy not
easy not easy so I just got to be
mindful when he whistles cuz that's when
it calls assistance
oh oh that don't look good that no
that's not good I don't know what that
is
whoa whoa whoa whoa what the hell whoa
whoa whoa oh whoa whoa whoa buddy whoa
whoa hahaha
yeah whatever shut up man all right I
know what to do here this must do a lot
of damage like I'm not gonna like this
must do like an incredible amount of
damage cuz it seems super worth it well
that's that's no good oh wait not bad
not bad
easy Oh shark incoming okay I know that
whoa okay come on give me another they
sure does love to give me the slapper oh
god damn it
well I don't know what happened there
but that was that was not good
Oh goddamn Wow Oh oh holy [ __ ]
oh whoa what I didn't even know about
that oh it's so close Scott damn they're
dead duck all right I got this I got
this I got this I got this I got this
wall up I know all right dogs incoming
along with cannonballs all good if
you're ducking ducking ducking ducking
ducking ducking that pink beam seems
like you could slap a like a bunch oh
god I was looking right at the wrong
place Oh I'm flustered ducking oh yeah I
love this gun I love this gun this gun
is good this gun is you just wait for
the right opportunity and you hit them
hard I love that gun that is a good gun
that is a good gun that's a good gun
that's a good gun right now
Bam Bam Bam Bam that's a good gun I
still haven't managed to A+ anything but
that is a damn good gun but then again
that one seemed a lot easier than a lot
of the other ones so captain briny beard
who is by all accounts a human in this
weird world of creatures and cups all
right what do we got here perilous piers
well I don't know about that I imagine
is gonna be perfectly wonderful
oh it's so satisfying to mrs. Kapoor and
it gives tons of super per hit
never mind apparently no it gives no
snun super what the hell now come here
you not not now you're getting slapping
okay but if you don't hit your target is
next to useless I guess yeah come on you
you're being a bit of a sassy am i we're
coming well what oh that's yeah that
seems about right
did everyone else die when I died is
that like it's just a law this land it's
like bosses I'm fine with bosses are
just like you run and you blast them a
few times you'll learn their mechanics
but for like levels like this I don't
know why I have so much trouble
maybe it's because I'm terrible oh wait
I just run guys I realized the problem
the answer is I'm terrible forgot forgot
forgot I totally forgot about that fact
about see see what I mean
see what I mean guys Wow okay all right
yeah the easiest part it's always the
easiest parts like that it's always the
easiest parts that I died god I'm so
stupid it's also a really cool feature
how you you shoot when you - with this
thing you kind of - and like let go so
you can - and blast an enemy at the same
time very useful very very useful I'm
also being extremely facetious it's not
oh come on
see the easiest ones the easiest moments
is the only ones that actually oh god I
didn't go high enough really ah god damn
slap a [ __ ] know why that was those not
intentional in any way I just happened
to be three counts of stupid in a row I
ran away from a fish in fear I didn't
think I'd ever do that in my life but I
honestly ran out of well wow I am just
sucking back
it right now and I don't know why no oh
come on you sack of [ __ ] god damn you
oh god god damn it ah God
oh [ __ ] why is this one so hard this is
not hard you know I think it's because
I'm trying to be fancy with the gun it's
gonna go with the goddamn running gun
and that's it I don't care if it takes
longer to kill okay maybe I do care if
it takes longer to kill because holy
[ __ ] why does that take so long huh see
a little better a little better huh a
little better a little better oddly a
little better
no oh Sh oh boy I could do too
I don't even know I could do two of
those in a row okay very close this I
don't trust this at all what no what
didn't I
[Music]
what didn't I - there oh you got to be
kidding me
well you got to be yanking on my gourd
here we go here we go here we go here we
go the good stuff what we call a markup
our HQ the good stuff TM I see why oh
wait wait
how wait what wait Oh on your head I
didn't know that that was what's going
on here I was just I was under the
impression oh my god I have no idea
what's happening here I am so scared and
I I am just lost to the winds okay you
know ah God I didn't I had no idea
that's what was half I had no idea
that's what was happening there I am I'm
just you know I just don't know I don't
know what's going on in this world also
might I add this pier is disgusting the
freaking flying fish infestation is just
beyond terrible like if I saw all these
like barnacles on the sidewalk with eyes
that were spewing green [ __ ] I would be
very concerned you know I just I want to
come out and say it I know it's taking a
stance but I would be a little concerned
more than a little I'd be I'd have to
I'd have to call City Council meeting if
I saw this this is disgusting okay here
we go oh I see you in there huh you
thought I missed you okay good thing I
died all this other time so that I could
actually see that I'm really happy about
that
okay now I'm standing on your head I get
it okay go go buy the favorite friend my
favorite friend in the whole wide world
bonk you go faster if I bonk you what
the [ __ ] I followed by right be in here
really really the [ __ ] end I miss the
goddamn coin it was bright in front flip
dick and face oh my foot dick face god
I'm not gonna do it I'm gonna start over
and cuz [ __ ] that it's so stupid and
you're stupid ah I'm getting I'm getting
salty guys get it cuz I'm out of here
what that what that what that well no
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
the hell where you think you you came
from huh
what do you think you came from huh your
mother no no no no nothing that ugly
could have bird something as pretty as
you and let's consider that an insult or
something I don't know I don't know what
it was really save this bouncy bounce
for when I need it no I didn't save that
no I didn't I'm gonna get oh [ __ ] you I
didn't say I said it in my brain so the
bouncy bounce
for when you need it mark applied your
huh [ __ ]
I call myself markiplier in my brain by
the way that's just what I'd do like why
is this level giving me more agita than
any other level that I've faced
it's just I've beaten it already I've
beaten it twice now it's just a [ __ ]
coin I don't even know I'm not even a
completionist type it's just that it
insulted me that's really all it is this
was insulting no come on I want to do
this flawless I'm getting a [ __ ]
a-plus on this
I don't care who you are I don't really
don't care you're gonna get you're gonna
give me that A+ you're gonna give me
that a plus perfect on time skill
everything about me is so beautifully
done
oh yeah oh yeah wow I don't even want
the it why do I want the A+ yeah I've
beaten this already I didn't have any
standards before this as you all know I
don't have standards I just don't it's
not a part of me it's not what I do it's
not how I am
usually I'm just totally fine with
mediocrity like mediocrity is really
like it's the bread and butter of my
life you know just a good-enough is like
my slogan that's you you piece of [ __ ]
fish you [ __ ] fish that's what you are
you piece of [ __ ] uh-uh I don't know why
I don't know why I want this I do not
know why I want this I actually don't
want this [ __ ] now I'm in a hurry and
I'm never gonna get it because I'm in a
hurry and there's nothing I can do I
can't not be in a hurry for this I am
just going to [ __ ] it up now like that's
just my lot in life right now I am gonna
[ __ ] this up see god it's like a why am
i in a hurry
I don't I really don't need to be in a
hurry it's not something that's a
requirement right now no come on
why am I in a hurry why stop being a
nerd you piece of [ __ ] me me self me and
talk to me selves to stop being in a
goddamn hurry if I just if I oh [ __ ]
hell oh my god why am I so why am I so
like this why am I like this
why am I like this hey guys are asking
the same question why am I like this why
am I like this why I'm punishing myself
here no I'm punishing nobody but myself
that's the only thing I'm doing here I'm
making myself angry for no reason
there's absolutely nothing to gain out
of this this the A+ is meaningless and
I'm not even gonna get it I guarantee
you I'm gonna find another way to goof
this up okay I'm here it's fine I just
ill hate that hate that hate that hate
that hate that whoa whoa aah
No what the [ __ ] keep hitting me god
damn it you didn't tell me that you
[Music]
no no what no god dammit
I [ __ ] what the [ __ ] god [ __ ]
damnit just stop mark just I'm talking
to I'm begging myself just stop being an
[ __ ] just stop just get to life level
over with and oh really [ __ ] god
dammit and then I realize like there's
nothing I can do my god there's nothing
I can do right now I'm stuck in a loop
until I get this I don't know why this
is how my brain works I've become so
fixated and I can recognize I can know I
can know it's wrong I can know what I'm
doing is stupid I know it in my head I
know it my body will not understand my
body rejects any [ __ ] semblance of
logic my brain can be like this is the
stupidest thing I'm doing why am I still
on this map I have beaten this many
times now and I'm still [ __ ] playing
it why there's no excuse for it
I have no reason oh my god there's no
reason I cannot get out of this loop I
am not joking this is not playing up
anything [ __ ] hell this is not
playing up anything I cannot [ __ ]
stop this is just my curse I just can't
do it this is how I am as a person if
you want any insight to me as a person
this is me because I can't [ __ ] let
it go I don't like I like things go it's
not that I don't let things go that
bother me I can very easily when it
comes to real-life [ __ ] I can let it go
but when something thinks that it's
[ __ ] better than me oh you better
[ __ ] believe I'm gonna go the ends of
the earth to make sure you burn to the
ground you piece of [ __ ] I will destroy
my entire life to prove someone wrong oh
god [ __ ] I don't want it I don't want it
I don't want it it's unhealthy to want
it it's unhealthy to want it I just want
to finish this
god that's how [ __ ] close I was why
why why was I stuck in that loop I don't
know why I know I could have done that I
know I could have brought one more try
and I would have had it but why did I
put myself through that oh I wouldn't
have gotten an A anyway I wouldn't have
got it cuz I didn't parry enough
apparently God I don't understand I
don't understand myself I don't
understand but that's all the time I got
for this episode of cop had I'm sorry it
was so stressful at the end there but
think how stressful it was for me please
have mercy on me I am a weird individual
and I can't control these things I want
to very badly anyway thank you everybody
so much for watching it's the reason why
I'm not giving up on this and it's weird
the reason I'm not giving up on giving
getting over it so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]